bien monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur on a un président de la
délégation collectivité territoriale
monsieur le Premier Vice-Président de la
chers collègues donc je vous prie tout
d'abord d'excuser le président de la
Mission Jérôme Bacher mais qui est
retenu par des obligations et des petits
problèmes de santé et qui ne peut être
avec nous mais qui je sais nous regarde
et que je tenais à excuser auprès de
vous cet après-midi et évidemment que je
vais tenter de suppléer en qualité de
vice-présidente de cette mission alors
cette mission est assez début parce que
nous l'avons installé mardi dernier
c'était le moment là nous avons élu
c'est même mercredi dernier nous avons
élu le bureau de cette mission
d'information et c'est notre première
audition monsieur le ministre qui tombe
si j'ose le dire à pique puisque c'est
aussi justement où vous le venez de
remettre votre rapport personnel du
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
et donc puisque nos travaux vont se
croiser c'était important en lien avec
la délégation en collectivité
territoriale que vous connaissez bien de
pouvoir avoir cette audition cette
après-midi où vous pourrez nous faire
part de vos premières analyses sur
effectivement les conséquences
des normes sur l'évolution budgétaire
des collectivités territoriales alors
cette mission je vous disais entame
aujourd'hui ces travaux puisque vous
êtes notre première personnalité
auditionnée et je vous rappelle chers
collègues en raison des des échéances
électorales qui concernent le Sénat au
mois de septembre prochain nous
souhaitons pouvoir achever nos travaux
courants du mois de juin prochain et
c'est pour ça que c'est délai assez
court nous impose un rythme de travail
un peu intense et une première au genre
réunion aujourd'hui alors dans un
contexte on est
désolé monsieur le ministre un peu
compliqué puisque c'est en pleine
réforme vous le savez des retraites et
que je sais que les accès au Sénat sont
pas si simple et les accès à Paris sont
pas simples que cela cet après-midi j'en
profite aussi pour appeler à nos
collègues que en lien avec la délégation
collectivité territoriale nous pourrons
organiser une audition au mois de mai
prochain qui permettra d'avoir là aussi
le moyen de croiser nos regards sur nos
objectifs communs à savoir et bien
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
territoriales alors
c'est vrai que c'est d'autant plus
important que nombre d'entre nous
faisons partie à la fois de la mission
et de la délégation collectivité
territoriale donc c'est bien d'avoir une
certaine unité pas pour faire trop
d'écart et et d'abdominaux d'où
l'importance de travailler ensemble donc
j'en profite pour saluer évidemment la
présence de la présidente de la
délégation Françoise Gatel ainsi que de
son premier vice-président Rémy
Pointreau qui a d'ailleurs une
compétence toute patte particulière en
matière de simplification des normes
sujet qu'il a pris à bras le corps et
pour lequel nous venons tu viens de
rendre un rapport important au nom de la
délégation et qui donnera lieu à un
séminaire la semaine prochaine pour
approfondir ce sujet cher aux élus
locaux alors avant de conclure et de
vous aider la parole je tiens d'abord à
vous saluer monsieur le Président Alain
Lambert je suis très heureuse
d'accueillir ici un Normand qui vient
grâce à votre grande connaissance du
sujet éclairé notre réflexion sur ce
sujet que vous connaissez par cœur
Françoise Gatel vous appelle d'ailleurs
toujours le chasseur de normes et donc
on voit bien que c'est ici le cœur de
notre sujet et donc je vous merci je
vais péter tout de suite la parole à la
rapporteur Ghislaine panel qui va
pouvoir introduire nos travaux j'en
profite pour vous redire que ces travaux
sont retransmis en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat donc la parole
maintenant à Madame la rapporteur merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
ministre Alain Lambert merci merci
d'avoir accepté de venir à cette
audition madame la Présidente chère
Françoise monsieur le vice-président
merci aussi d'être là mes chers
collègues le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen a
souhaité que le Sénat mène une réflexion
sur l'impact qu'on crée des décisions
réglementaires et budgétaires de l'État
sur l'équilibre financier des
collectivités locales pourquoi pour
compte un sujet parce qu'il nous semble
que l'État au sens large impose aux
collectivités toujours davantage de
normes et de contraintes budgétaires
direct ou indirectes au détriment de
l'efficacité de l'action publique locale
je pense en particulier au plus petites
collectivité dans les ressources
techniques et financières sont limitées
dans le cadre de cette mission nous
distinguerons les décisions
réglementaires et les décisions
budgétaires les décisions réglementaires
concernent les décrets et arrêtés dont
on sait qu'ils imposent d'énormes de
plus en plus nombreuses aux
collectivités locales sur ce point de la
délégation au collectivités
territoriales du Sénat vient de rendre
un rapport sur l'addiction aux normes il
soulignent par exemple que le code
général des collectivités territoriales
à tripler de volume en 20 ans n'était
pas aujourd'hui le million de mots la
délégation organise aussi dans les états
généraux de la simplification
pardon oui oui c'est ça le jeudi 16 mars
procès prochain cette manifestation
auquel le cnen est très directement
associé présentera les conclusions d'une
récente consultation menée auprès des
élus sur la question du poids des normes
je laisserai sur ce point Madame cattel
et Monsieur pointeaux ont été mon propos
s'il le souhaite je tire à les remercier
vraiment pour cette belle initiative les
décisions budgétaires quant à elles sont
davantage circonscrits mais n'en demeure
pas moins toujours plus pesante à la
fois sur les recettes et les dépenses
des collectivités
essentiellement concentré sur les textes
législatifs de nature financière ces
décisions ont réduit après année la
libre administration des collectivités
et leur autonomie financière principe
pourtant consacré dans notre
Constitution sur ce point nous interroge
nous interrogerons le Comité des
finances locales présidé par Alain
Deniel mais vous avez peut-être David
autant que vous avez récemment proposé
une fusion entre les CNN et CFN
vous l'avez compris notre objectif dans
le cas de cette mission sera de
déterminer exemple concret à l'appui si
ces décisions réglementaires et
budgétaires de l'État compromettent ou
non l'équilibre financier des
collectivités en particulier sur les
communes rurales
cette analyse suppose bien sûr
d'examiner
ceci les décisions de l'État sont
précédées d'une évaluation complète
sérieuse et sincère quant à leur impact
notamment budgétaire ou collectivités
sur les collectivités territoriales sur
ce point de CNN joue un rôle déterminant
et c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité
débuter notre cycle d'audition par celle
de Monsieur Alain Lambert vous monsieur
Lambert le dynamique président de cette
instance monsieur le Président je vous
remercie très sincèrement pour votre
présence aujourd'hui votre audition
tombe si je veux dire à pic puisque vous
avez rendu hier votre rapport d'activité
sur la période 2019-2022 il est
d'ailleurs distribué sur table
vous avez été monsieur le Président
destinataire de questionnaire donc je ne
serai donc pas plus longue je vous
propose de évidemment de vous céder la
parole je vous rappelle à toutes et à
tous que cette audition est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat je
vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur peut-être
monsieur le Président sans attendre et
puis nous procéderons ensuite
je crois qu'aucun gouvernement ne
l'aurait souhaité et donc ça a été la
volonté du Parlement sur une proposition
du Sénat qui a permis en 2012 de fonder
le cnen
nous sommes un organe dont je vais vous
dire un mot dans un instant du rôle des
élus qui siège en son sein c'est un
organe qui n'a pas d'orgueil d'auteur
d'orgueil d'existentielle c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui le conduit parfois à
imaginer sa fusion avec un autre organe
mais nous nous attachons par exemple à
nous comparer à d'autres organes de pays
voisins donc nous sommes comparés à un
organe allemand qu'on appelle le NKR et
qui a l'avantage de disposer de pouvoir
plus étendu que ce dont nous disposons
et d'avoir obtenu un nombre de réduction
de dépenses qui est tout à fait
substantielle et nous sommes à votre
disposition pour vous donner toutes les
informations relatives à ce cette
comparaison que nous avons effectué
pour revenir plus précisément à la
question des élus je voudrais vous dire
que le rôle des élus
rassemblés au sein d'un collège auquel
dans lequel siège d'ailleurs Françoise
Gatel a une responsabilité importante
puisque le collège des élus est
majoritaire au sein du cnen il existe un
collège des administrations qui lui est
minoritaire mais lorsque nous sommes au
complet et en général nous sommes
toujours plus nombreux que le collège
des administrations nous avons la
majorité au sein du conseil ce qui nous
permet de délibérer avec une très grande
liberté ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous
avons pour autant une décision qui soit
définitive mais en tout cas nous pouvons
émettre nos avis de manière tout à fait
indépendante alors en fait
au fil des années puisque nous sommes
nés en 2012 mais nous succédions à une
commission consultative qui était née
elle en 2008 nous avons maintenant une
très grande expérience nous sommes
aperçus que le calcul des coûts liés au
norme
imposés par l'État et extrêmement
important mais le calcul des
conséquences d'un droit imparfait et
aussi très très important parce qu'il
n'y a pas que les dépenses directes qui
sont liées à une mesure nouvelle il y a
aussi les complexités administratives
qui sont entourées du dispositif nouveau
qui a été imposé par le gouvernement et
donc nous sommes attachés à travailler
sur la qualité des droits et à son
applicabilité la plus facile
applicabilité au niveau du terrain parce
que c'est ce qui nous paraît le plus
important c'est pourquoi nous avons
travaillé en liaison directe avec par
exemple Conseil d'État qui est un
partenaire avec laquelle avec lequel
nous avons organisé récemment
un colloque et nous travaillons avec
d'autres organes comme le secrétariat
général du gouvernement et naturellement
avec la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales voilà ce que je peux vous
dire si vous voulez sur le rôle du cnen
bien sûr à l'occasion des questions des
membres de votre mission je répondrai
peut-être plus de manière plus concrète
à des questions pratiques que les
membres de la de la mission peuvent se
poser
je voulais pas faire un non le tunnel
c'est pour ça que je m'arrête en
première question
une liste assez importante de questions
donc voilà si vous voulez bien pour
suivre peut-être vous m'avez posé la
question de savoir pourquoi le cnen
n'est pas n'était pas saisi des lois de
finances alors c'est vrai qu'il n'est
pas saisi des lois de finances il va
dire vrai il ne s'en est jamais plaint
mais nous verrons dans un instant qu'il
s'est souvent plein de ne pas être saisi
des lois de programmation des finances
publiques s'agissant des lois de
finances il nous est toujours apparu
qu'elles sont en serrées et un ancien
président de la commission des finances
du Sénat et ancien rapporteur général
des budget peut en parler nous sommes en
serrés dans des délais qui sont
tellement courts que notre avis n'est
pas vraiment opérant pour le Parlement
je dois dire d'ailleurs que le Parlement
est compétent pour nous saisir et qu'il
ne l'a jamais fait ce qui veut dire que
lui-même est dans une sorte de de
cascade qui ne lui enfin qui ne rend pas
la vie de CNN extrêmement utile
seul étant ça ne veut pas dire que ne
regardons nous ne regardons pas le texte
mais pour revenir à une
une information que vous avez donné tout
à l'heure nous pensons que c'est
davantage le rôle du Comité des finances
locales lequel est un organe qui lui est
doit être obligatoirement saisie en
matière de loi de finances je dois dire
d'ailleurs que les ministres des du
budget se présente toujours avant de se
présenter au Parlement devant le Comité
des finances locales pour présenter les
mesures qui ont un impact sur les
budgets des finances locales cela est
ainsi vous me le permettez je peux par
contre vous dire un mot des lois de
programmation alors c'est un sujet
extrêmement important vous connaissez le
destin de la loi de programmation qui
n'a pas été adoptée par le Parlement et
qui donc n'existe pas d'un point de vue
juridique nous n'avons pas été saisi
nous en avons été surpris nous avons
exprimé d'ailleurs notre embarras parce
que ça n'est pas une question d'orgueil
encore une fois c'est une question tout
simplement de pouvoir examiner
normalement un gouvernement doit être
fier des lois de programmation qu'il
propose ça n'est pas un texte anodin
qu'on présente en catiminée donc si on
est là-bas une stratégie budgétaire pour
5 années on doit pouvoir l'assumer
devant tous les organes dans dispose de
la République je dois dire que alors là
je l'ai appris à la commission des
finances de Sénat je ne suis pas fan des
lois de programmation des finances
publiques parce que c'est un débat
franco-français en revanche je vous
recommande très vivement je le fais très
humblement mais je vous recommande très
vivement de vous intéresser beaucoup
plus au programme de stabilité parce que
le programme de stabilité ça n'est pas
un document franco-français c'est un
document qui engage la France vis-à-vis
de tous ses partenaires européens et
croyez moi il contient un certain nombre
de stratégies en tout cas de
d'orientation qu'on ne retrouve pas
obligatoirement dans la loi de
programmation figurez-vous que ce sont
deux actes budgétaires extrêmement
importants qui sont fabriqués au mauvais
au même moment mais ils sont ils sont
pas articulés l'un avec l'autre ce qui
est tout à fait paradoxal et ce qui nous
a conduit nous pour ce qui nous concerne
à ne pas accorder un très grand intérêt
à la loi de programmation mais à
accorder un intérêt beaucoup plus
important au programme de stabilité
d'ailleurs je dois dire que dans la
situation présente la loi de
programmation n'existe pas puis le
programme de stabilité lui existe donc
si encore une fois je je pouvais vous
présenter humblement encore une fois une
recommandation je vous je vous inviterai
à attacher la plus grande importance au
programme de stabilité pour nous les
programmes de stabilité depuis qu'ils
existent c'est-à-dire depuis 1999 à tort
ne donne pas suffisamment d'informations
sur les relations financières entre
l'État et collectivité territorial de
sorte que nous avons le sentiment que
les trajectoires de finances publiques
sont tellement rédigées de telle manière
qu'on a l'impression que les finances
des collectivités territoriales sont la
variable d'ajustement des finances
publiques et c'est à mon avis à
l'occasion du programme de stabilité qui
serait extrêmement intéressant de
demander davantage d'informations au
gouvernement sur cette partie qui
apparaît comme la variable d'ajustement
et qui est celle des collectivités
territoriales et qui est quand même
l'essentiel de l'application du de des
politiques publiques dans l'ensemble des
pays voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire
sur les lois de finance et les lois de
programmation des finances publiques
alors je ne sais pas si je continue
en même temps je ne veux pas être trop
long donc je vais essayer d'aller plus
rapidement et après vous pourrez
m'interpeller autant que vous le vous le
souhaiterez vous m'avez demandé ce que
je pensais de la certification des
études d'impact je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs une proposition de la
délégation alors en cette matière
naturellement nous pensons que la
certification des études d'impact serait
extrêmement utiles cela étant je ne vous
cache pas que les études d'impact me
plonge dans un très grand embarras je ne
comprends pas bien la politique
française sur ce sujet voilà qu'en 2008
le constituant à adopter le principe de
l'obligation d'une étude d'impact dont
les modalités ont été inscrites dans une
loi organique de 2009
c'est pas rien quand le constituant
considère qu'il faut cesser de légiférer
à l'aveugle et de réglementer à
l'aveugle et qu'il faut impérativement
faire précéder la loi ou le règlement
d'une étude d'impact
le constitument le décide le légisateur
organique l'organisme et depuis
les pouvoirs exécutifs n'ont cessé
d'essayer d'échapper aux contraintes de
l'étude d'impact je vous avoue que je
n'y comprends rien je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on érige au firmament de notre
Constitution l'obligation d'une étude
d'impact comme si c'était vraiment
important et comment au lendemain on
cherche par tous les moyens à éviter
s'agissant de la certification des
études d'impact je dois vous dire que le
certificateur aujourd'hui n'aurait pas
beaucoup de difficultés parce que elles
sont d'une insuffisance d'elle que on
arriverait très très vite à les
considérer comme tel cela étant si nous
espérons que elle pourrait s'améliorer
je crois que en effet il y a eu il y
aurait utilité à scandale est-ce que le
cnen est le mieux placé ne pouvons en
parler mais un organe puisse les
certifier ainsi que la délégation en a
émis le souhait parce que ça permettrait
dans l'hypothèse où elles sont
insuffisantes de demander de les
améliorer davantage cela étant je vous
ferai remarquer sans balises encore que
que le législateur organique a prévu que
les conférences des présidents des deux
assemblées peuvent refuser d'inscrire le
texte à l'ordre du jour s'il considère
que l'étude d'impact est insuffisante à
ma connaissance ceci n'a jamais été fait
donc vous voyez bien que on ne peut pas
non plus demandé à un organe comme le
CNN qui est tout en étant
respectable on a quand même pas la force
et la puissance
d'une de conférence des présidents je
voudrais vous dire que l'insuffisance de
l'étude d'impact c'est un mal profond de
la législation française
j'en viens si vous voulez aux questions
relatives aux études d'impact en général
celle-ci mais également l'étude des
coûts financiers des textes à la fois
législatifs réglementaires
en observant ce que fait l'Allemagne
c'est à dire l'équivalent de CNN en
Allemagne
nous sommes aperçus que cette organe à
l'avantage de pouvoir travailler avec un
département
issu de l'organe de statistiques
nationales c'est-à-dire l'Office
national de statistiques l'Office le
fils fédéral de statistiques allemands à
un département qui est consacré aux
finances des collectivités territoriales
et à l'ensemble des dépenses et recettes
des collectivités territoriales et
l'équivalent du cnen allemand
a un droit de tirage permanent sur les
travaux de cette Insee allemande si vous
voulez et nous pensons nous que la
création de ce département au sein de
l'Insee serait extrêmement utile pour le
CNN pour la délégation collectivité
territoriale pour le Parlement général
pourquoi ça ne se fait pas ben tout
simplement faut dire les choses nous
sommes dans un pays la France
extrêmement centralisée et si l'Insee
est indépendant
il faut quand même qu'il soit pas trop
loin de gouvernement si vous voulez je
parle pas de ce gouvernement je parle de
tous les gouvernements et donc je crois
que le débat doit être ouvert parce que
il me paraît gaspiller un petit peu
d'énergie et d'argent public en ayant un
organisme aussi puissant aussi utile que
l'INSEE et le voir dans l'impossibilité
de donner des informations à tous les
organes qui travaillent pour le compte
des collectivités territoriales voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sur ce sujet
vous m'avez également interrogé sur la
question du rattachement nous ne pensons
que le cnen a vécu autant qu'il ne
pouvait jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais il faut
réfléchir au futur
nous avons voulu que nous n'avions pas
d'orgueil de
d'existence d'orgueil existentiel en
évoquant la fusion du Comité des
finances locales et de du cnen c'était
pour montrer que nous étions ouverts à
toutes les hypothèses cela étant c'est
quelque chose qui nécessite un
dispositif législatif assez lourd et je
ne le vois pas possible à un horizon
visible voilà pourquoi nous avons des
propositions annexes que nous avons
d'ailleurs souvent présenté à la
délégation nous pensons que le
rapprochement le plus approprié serait
le rapprochement avec le secrétariat
général de gouvernement dire que
l'organe qui nous saisit sur tous les
textes législatifs à réglementaires et
le secrétariat général de gouvernement
il ne paraîtrait utile d'être rattaché à
lui de manière à ce que nous ayons un
lien direct avec lui que nous puissions
mieux mesurer ce qu'il attend de nous et
que nous puissions l'alerter sur ce qui
nous paraît in
pour l'instant je ne vois pas ce qui
s'oppose à se rattachement sauf la
tradition française c'est que lorsque
nous sommes nés nous avons été rattachés
à la Délégation
générale des collectivités territoriales
et que des choses étant installées ainsi
il faudrait que jusqu'à de vitam eternal
nous restions attachés à la direction
générale des collectivités territoriales
je ne pense pas que cette situation soit
idéale dans le pour le présent et dans
le futur quand on songe que je pars 30 à
40% des textes qui nous sont soumis
proviennent de la Direction générale des
collectivités territoriales donc
l'organe qui nous saisit de ses propres
textes et l'organe qui assure notre
secrétariat et auquel nous sommes
rattachés ça ne semble pas si vous
voulez idéal comme organisation voilà
pourquoi nous plaidons pour la
délégation pour le rattachement au
secrétariat général du Gouvernement si
ça n'est pas de la compétence du
Parlement le Parlement pourrait émettre
dans ces travaux un avis sur ce sujet
lequel nous nous rendrait service
vous nous avez posé la question des
moyens humains matériels et financiers
d'ailleurs notre rattachement est lié à
ça c'est que aujourd'hui nous vous avez
une grande partie des équipes de CNN qui
sont à ma droite là ce qui vous montre
que nous avons des effectifs qui sont
tout de même restreints et je veux dire
que je les salue pour le travail de de
moins de soldats qui les accomplissent
je voudrais vous dire que sur ce sujet à
chaque fois qu'un organe dit qu'il
manque de moyens pour le vieux
budgétaire que je suis on se pose
toujours des questions parce que
pourquoi dépenser plus si ça n'apporte
pas des contreparties je trouve que
investir dans des moyens humains
matériels et financiers pour le c.a.n ce
serait financièrement rentable parce que
notre pays
engage par ses lois et par ses
règlements des dépenses qu'il a plutôt
collectivité derrière éditoriale à un
niveau excessif et que s'il y avait un
organe régulateur probablement
arriverait-il à freiner cette dépense
qui est ainsi réputée au collectivités
territoriales voilà pourquoi je pense
que cet investissement humain serait
facilement rentabilisé
alors qui peut en décider moi je crois
que faut cesser de l'attendre du
pouvoir exécutif entre nous le pouvoir
exécutif sans cnen sans porterait mieux
donc n'attendons pas de sa part qu'il
l'acte qu'il l'améliore les moyens du
cnen en revanche moi j'ai envie de vous
dire la balle est dans votre camp
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
parce que sauf erreur de ma part c'est
le Parlement qui vote le budget et donc
si vous souhaitiez que les moyens de CNN
dans le cadre si vous voulez peut-être
d'une réforme qui viderait notamment à
sa rattachement sous une autre forme
je crois que vous pourriez donner des
signaux budgétaire dans ce domaine et je
crois que ce serait vraiment l'occasion
de le faire parce que ça ouvrirait au
moins un débat
je termine
souvent on dit qu'on termine et on ne le
fait pas alors là je vais quand même
terminer sur
l'opinion que je me fais sur les
problèmes juridiques que les
collectivités territoriales rencontrent
pour dire que on ne peut pas être dans
une situation aussi excessive sans que
les responsabilités soient partagées
le gouvernement a un arsenal de
production de normes qui est
illimité
euh vous savez quand on est ancien on
finit de temps en temps ben être
sollicité pour parler à aux jeunes
générations moi ce qui me fera beaucoup
dans les amendements parlementaires et
vous imaginez que nous les regardons
c'est que par exemple il comporte des
dispositions que je vous invite sauf
dans des cas particuliers je vous invite
à renoncer quand vous déposez un
amendement tout à fait utile pourquoi
vous sentez-vous obligé lorsqu'il est
une application toute simple d'ajouter
que le Conseil d'État un décret en
Conseil d'État déterminera des
conditions d'application de la présente
mesure
si le début de l'enfer
votre mesure simple d'application va
tomber entre les mains
de d'experts qui vont prévoir un
dispositif à cracher le sang
pardonnez-moi l'expression qui vont
organiser un système de contrôle par la
mémoire encore plus à cracher le sang et
qui vont assister à un régime de
pénalité de choses comme ça vous entrez
dans l'enfer absolu et donc moi je crois
que sauf dans les cas particuliers il
faut absolument éviter que vous renvoyez
un décret donc on voit bien que il y a
des il y a des des mesures que nous
pouvons prendre pour alléger la
législation et la réglementation qui
frappe les collectivités territoriales
voilà ce que je pourrais vous dire en
introduction j'ai déjà été beaucoup trop
long mais ce qui est le plus vivant
c'est généralement de se soumettre aux
questions des
membres de la de la mission merci aussi
beaucoup monsieur le Président pour
cette introduction madame la rapporteur
avez-vous des questions supplémentaires
j'aurai une question monsieur le
Président une question supplémentaire
dans le rapport public d'activité du
cnen sortie tout récemment vous évoquez
dans votre conclusion de la nécessité de
produire un droit collaboratif fondé sur
la concertation la confiance et la
responsabilité pour ne pas oublier les
destinataires des normes qui sont
produites
très concrètement comment voyez-vous le
fonctionnement de ce nouveau système
dont vous parlez
je vais vous donner un exemple pour que
ça soit plus concret cette formule un
peu un peu technocratique
alors avant la décentralisation lorsque
une réforme était engagée le
gouvernement de cette époque
interrogé les services déconcentrés pour
savoir comment la réforme qu'il se
proposait de réaliser serait la plus
appropriée pour pouvoir atteindre des
objectifs que le gouvernement
poursuivait et vous avez vous êtes tous
très jeunes mais certains d'entre vous
ont connu les DDE c'est des gens qui
occupaient
qui exercent des responsabilités
importantes etc donc tous les services
déconcentrés de l'État étaient
interrogés dans la phase avant
l'écriture de la loi dans la phase de
préparation de la loi
après la décentralisation il me semble
que les services n'ont pas déconcentrés
encore qu'il serait qu'il est toujours
utile de les interroger mais que les
services les administrations
décentralisées
territoriales soient associées en amont
de la mesure que le gouvernement
envisage généralement ce sont des
mesures qui sont destinées à favoriser
l'application des politiques publiques
je trouve qu'il est
inefficace de le faire de Paris sans
interroger ceux qui vont avoir la
responsabilité pratique de mettre en
oeuvre les dispositions voilà pour voilà
pourquoi nous appelons ça un droit
collaboratif c'est un droit qui est
élaboré en relation avec les
destinataires de ce droit avec ceux qui
vont appliquer ce droit ça ne veut pas
dire que le gouvernement n'aurait pas le
dernier mot mais au moins il aurait en
amont opéré sa concertation alors
qu'aujourd'hui souvent il le fait en
aval nous au CN nous passons notre temps
à demander aux administrations qui
viennent présenter leur texte
réglementaire leur dire avez-vous
consulté des collectivités territoriales
une fois sur deux on nous dit ah bah non
on les a pas consultés donc vous voyez
bien à quel point ce droit collaboratif
serait un grand progrès
merci Madame la rapporteur je pense
quand même la présidente de la
délégation collectivité chez Françoise a
une question merci madame la Présidente
merci Madame la rapporteur de nous avons
invité vraiment nous nous réjouissons de
ce travail en synergie je salue le
président lombaire qui se définit
lui-même comme un moine soldat je
qualifierais d'excellence parce que pour
être membre du sénéen je sais combien
nous pouvons ici au Sénat lui rendre un
hommage qu'il est une vraie dit que sur
parfois ce qu'on va appeler le délire
normatif donc Rémi pintro on parlera
sûrement à la délégation nous avons
travaillé puisque c'est la fonction
essentielle de Rémi sur la
simplification et au-delà de ce qui est
à marronnier une désolation perpétuelle
qui nous coûte fort cher nous avons
essayé de réfléchir à la fabrique de la
loi parce que force est de constater
vous l'avez dit administration des plus
performantes mais puissantes qui parfois
s'autorise à penser à la place du
législateur et surtout à la place de
ceux qui sont condamnés à mettre à
exécution les choses et surtout moi ce
qui me frappe contenu de l'importance de
votre sujet et on l'a vu sur la loi
mobilité avec Madame borne donc nous
philosophons sur un objet extrêmement
intéressant les mobilités on décide que
ces mobilités sont essentielles
aujourd'hui
à la fois pour la transition énergétique
mais aussi pour des enclavés des
territoires alors on est tous
merveilleusement d'accord en confiant
aux régions une compétence et quelqu'un
dans l'assistance très éveillée dit il
faudrait qu'on parle un peu d'argent
c'est à dire combien ça coûte et quel
argent a-t-on le faire et on nous répond
ben écoutez ça ce sujet là sera traité
avec la loi de finances or donc nous
arrivons à fabriquer une loi sans qu'il
y ait vraiment d'appréciation des coûts
et que quand nous arrivons au moment de
la loi pertinence nous ne traitons plus
avec le ministre qui portait ce qui
était une bonne idée mec Bercy et Bercy
pardonnez-moi monsieur le ministre que
vous en fûtes et plutôt du genre
coskiller évite de penser parce que
sinon sa vie dramatique donc on a on a
là un vrai sujet sur les études d'impact
des gens terminerai là il y a
effectivement obligation de faire une
étude d'impact elles sont souvent
indigentes et vous l'avez dit vous-même
c'est assez fascinant de voir que
l'étude d'impact est fabriqué par les
services du ministère qui prônent ce
projet de loi donc naturellement le
ministre va éviter de se contrarier et
donc je pense qu'il est nécessaire qu'il
y a un organisme
indépendant et que surtout quand le CNN
négatif cette avis négatif
le ministère au point il va s'efforcer
d'améliorer les choses pour recueillir
un avis positif parce qu'au final c'est
bien l'applicabilité
de la loi et qu'à force Yori dans un
moment où l'argent est rare il me semble
important que la norme elle soit dosée
pour être pertinente et non pas
impertinente et parfois nous condamner à
être empêché de faire
je sais pas si vous voulez répondre même
s'il y a pas de question de fond mais
bien le sujet de fond mais pas de
question précise
présidente de la délégation et c'est
vrai que nous travaillons je parle sur
votre contrôle à tous les deux nous
travaillons en permanence ensemble et je
vais dire que c'est très utile pour nous
parce que il est important que nous
puissions alerter le Parlement sur ce
que nous constatons dans les réactions
des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président merci
juste quelques mots parce que ma
collègue Françoise Gatel a tout dit pour
d'abord saluer le travail
de Madame canaillé et de Madame Pantel
sur le coût financier de des normes
parce que il est il est assez énorme
et puis saluer aussi le travail de du
président Lambert parce que il travaille
avec peu de moyens
féliciter aussi son équipe parce que
quand on est une étude d'impact trois
jours ou quatre jours avant la décision
et la mise en place du texte dans les
hémicycles ça me paraît un peu difficile
juste pour dire que effectivement donc
l'inflation
normative complexifie évidemment le les
projets locaux
les retardent donc ça veut dire que
c'est frein à la croissance aussi c'est
peut-être qu'il faudrait le mettre dans
le coup supplémentaire je pensais que
vous avez évalué à 2 milliards et demi
le surcoût c'est à peu près ça mais
est-ce qu'on a évalué également le
problème du retard parce que quand on
dit retard ça veut dire coût
supplémentaire et ça ça serait peut-être
intéressant
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas de
thermomètre qui nous permet de mesurer
la fièvre normative à part de savoir que
le code général des collectivités
territoriales a augmenté de trois fois
son volume
de dire également que les études
d'impact évidemment il faut qu'elle soit
donnée bien en amont de de l'étude par
le CNN et puis surtout nous ce qu'on va
ce qu'on avait proposé dans la fessie
propositions dans notre rapport avec ma
collègue Françoise gataine notre
présidente
que l'étude d'impact se divise en deux
en deux parties une première partie qui
serait une étude n'a pas de d'option ou
d'opportunités d'abord pour savoir si la
norme est justifiée
et ensuite de faire véritablement une
étude d'impact qui soit à la fois
sincère objectif et qui soit
indépendante parce qu'aujourd'hui comme
le disait tout à l'heure
Françoise Gatel notre Président
c'est de l'auto justification qu'on fait
c'est le gouvernement
s'auto justifie de ce de sa norme qui va
mettre en place donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet il faut absolument qu'on arrive à
avoir des études d'impact indépendantes
après appliquer la règle du 2 pour 1
c'est à dire qu'on supprime deux normes
pour une mise en place et puis il y a un
autre sujet que je voulais évoquer mais
ça c'est par rapport au décret
d'application peut-être que le président
pourra nous éclairer
aujourd'hui les décrets d'applications
on les constatent une fois qu'ils ont
été publiés est-ce qu'il serait pas
judicieux que les décrets d'application
soit soumis aux commissions qui ont
travaillé sur les textes
on l'a vu pour le point des Duan où on a
eu des décrets d'applications qui
correspondent pas du tout au texte qui a
été voté et ça permettrait d'éviter
parfois des normes supplémentaires et de
faire en sorte que on évite des coûts
supplémentaires par dû parfois
l'administration parce que quand on
parle de responsabilité partagée le
gouvernement bien sûr nous-mêmes
législateur parce qu'on est des premiers
parfois à ajouter des normes on est trop
précis parfois dans les dans les
amendements que nous déposons peut-être
qu'il faudrait être plus souple
et puis
évidemment l'administration qui parfois
dans les décrets d'application n'a pas
toujours le la bonne lecture de ce qui a
été voté
merci monsieur le Premier
remarques sur les études d'option qui
n'existent pas je crois que
Rémi a tout à fait raison là encore la
loi organique imprévue que les lois que
les
impacts étaient destinés à donner au
Parlement les différentes options qui
étaient sur la table pour atteindre les
objectifs prévus par la loi et expliquer
les raisons pour lesquelles c'est tel ou
telle option qui avait été choisi et
bien lorsque vous regardez les études
d'impact aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'option ce qui veut dire que l'option
retenue apparaît comme la seule possible
et toute l'étude d'impact vise à
démontrer que c'est la seule la seule
solution possible
auquel cas je me demande par quoi on a
prévu dans la loi organique qui devait y
avoir plusieurs options sur les décrets
d'application dans le rapport
d'activités que nous avons publié nous
sommes plein beaucoup des saisines en
urgence voir en extrait urgence comment
voulez-vous en effet que nous ayons le
temps de saisir la commission au fond
saisie au fond du Parlement où les deux
commissions saisies au fond du Parlement
sur la loi elle-même pour examiner si
les décrets d'applications sont bien
dans l'esprit du législateur si nous
n'avons 48 heures pour le faire donc
vous vous rendez bien compte que l'usage
et l'abus de l'usage de l'urgence et de
l'extrême urgence est un moyen détourner
pour éviter précisément que le travail
d'appréciation de la qualité du texte
d'application et bon et que ce travail
est bon ou mauvais
et donc lorsque nous nous plaignons des
saisines en extraits d'urgence ce n'est
pas parce que nous voulons avoir le
confort de disposer de temps c'est que
nous voulons consulter tous ceux qui ont
été dans la chaîne d'élaboration des
droits
merci
la parole bien sûr en premier voilà
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
votre présence et puis de quelques
éléments ou des nombreux que vous nous
avez donné qui nous éclairent vraiment
sur l'importance du travail que fait le
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
alors moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié aussi
un rapport que vous avez relatif à
l'intelligibilité à la simplification
des normes applicables collectivités
territoriales au sein du service de
l'action publique que vous avez rendu en
février 2021 moi je voulais savoir où on
était où en été la prise en compte de
ses propositions que vous faisiez qui me
paraissait extrêmement intéressante et
particulièrement sur deux points sur
l'axe 2 qui était renforcé la portée du
principe de libre administration des
collectivités locales
surtout de préciser au niveau
constitutionnel et organique le contenu
du principe de libre administration et
effectivement bon je sais qu'il y a un
législatif de l'Association des maires
de France qui travaille sur ce sujet à
modifier l'article 34 pour introduire de
la Constitution mais qui travaille aussi
je voulais demander ce que vous en
pensez
au fait de de voir comment ça pourrait
se traduire dans une loi organique et
comment on pourrait le faire donc ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que cette proposition est
pris en compte ou que ce travail de
l'Association des maires de France peut
peu aboutir un jour ou non par une
initiative parlementaire ou peut-être
gouvernementale c'est ton jamais
l'autre c'est sur l'axe 4 qui est
d'assouplir l'exercice des compétences
relevant des collectivités territoriales
par l'évolution structurelle de la
culture normative et particulièrement la
proposition de 13 qui est de développer
le principe de différenciation
territoriale au niveau local en
particulier c'est un petit peu ce que
d'interprétation de certaines des normes
des normes par nos notre administration
territoriale
particulièrement par les préfets on voit
bien qu'au niveau du zan c'est pas du
tout ce qui au début ce qui a été retenu
c'est-à-dire que nos services de DDT et
nos préfets appliqués avant que la loi
soit sortie ce qui était prévu par la
loi du gouvernement donc effectivement
là on est dans une dans un travail de
l'administration centrale qui est quand
même en fait de l'administration y
compris locale et locale qui est quand
même un petit qui dépasse je pense un
petit peu ces attribution juste revenir
sur le premier dans le dans le le comité
législatif de l'Association des maires
de France il y a aussi un travail sur la
modification de l'article 72 de pour
pouvoir
comment dire évaluer dans le temps que
soyez régulièrement le coût le coup
quand on évalue un transfert de charge
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoires on évolue en même temps que
T et ça ne bouge jamais et donc c'est
pour travailler au fait de réévaluer
dans le temps le coût de cette
compétence pour pouvoir évaluer aussi
les charges qui sont à la charge des
collectivités locales là dessus je
voulais savoir ce que vous en pensez
merci monsieur le président
c'est une question des questions très
riches
je vais reprendre la première qui est le
principe à valeur constitutionnelle des
libre administration ce que nous
recommandons pour notre part c'est que
le législateur ne considère pas que la
vie du Conseil d'État ou la vie du
Conseil constitutionnel guide sa plume
vient un moment ou un principe aussi
sacré sur se dire si j'ose dire que
celui de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales mérite de
temps en temps que les législateurs
écrivent la conception qui est la sienne
du principe de libre administration on
verra toujours bien si cette conception
enrichit par des textes nouveaux
venaient à être contraire à la
Constitution moi personnellement je ne
pense pas je pense que de ce point de
vue là le Parlement depuis toujours à
probablement manqué d'audace je crois
qu'il peut
faut trouver des bonnes occasions pour
le faire il faut trouver des lois
organiques pour le faire mais il peut
probablement concourir à un principe de
libre administration renforcé
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on veut l'apprécier
on se réfère à la jurisprudence du
Conseil de constitutionnel et aux avis
du Conseil d'État
je suis désolé de dire
malgré l'immense respect que j'ai pour
ces institutions que ce rôle est entre
les mains dans un premier temps du
Parlement
sur
les
décrets
d'applications c'était tout à l'heure
sur le principe de différenciation vous
savez le meilleur moyen d'avoir un
principe de différenciation respectée
c'est d'éviter taux de trop de précision
dans la loi et dans les textes
réglementaires de manière à ce que le
droit qui est à appliquer puisse
s'appliquer à tous les échelons
territoriaux à tous les niveaux de
collectivité territoriales quel que soit
leur taille et quel que soit leur moyen
si vous commencez à prévoir des
dispositifs très différents selon le
territorial selon le
la population selon les moyens
financiers etc vous vous retrouvez avec
une somme de texte qui qui deviennent
qui devient une applicable voilà
pourquoi je pense que de ce point de vue
là nous ne pouvons obtenir une meilleure
application du principe de
différenciation je voudrais terminer
enfin terminer à l'occasion de cette
question vers vous mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je crois vraiment que vous
pourriez vous pouvez sur les
décrets d'application avoir une
influence à partir de vos amendements y
compris avec des amendements que vous
retirez pendant la discussion vous
pouvez apporter un amendement proposé un
amendement par exemple de précision pour
voir si le gouvernement a bien
l'intention d'appliquer le texte dans
tel ou tel orientation ou dans tel ou
tel mesure vous pouvez déposer un
amendement pour le faire parler sur ce
sujet lui demander si il a bien
l'intention de maintenir cette approche
dans les textes d'application et auquel
cas ça vous permet de retirer votre
amendement mais ça nous permet à nous au
moment où le texte d'application arrive
de dire attendez
c'est pas ce que le gouvernement a dit
au moment de de la discussion
parlementaire si le gouvernement avait
répondu dans le sens du décret peut-être
que l'article n'aurait pas été adopté
donc vous voyez bien ça nous donnerait à
nous des moyens de discuter de manière
plus concrète avec le pouvoir
réglementaire
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues que vous avez c'est
merci pour votre présence merci pour la
qualité de votre intervention moi
j'aurais une question assez assez direct
concernant la taille des collectivités
locales
vous vous savez naturellement et cette
nouveauté trans partisane donc je suis
très cool
connaissez naturellement cette volonté
depuis quelques années devoir grossir
nos collectivités territoriales à
travers des intercommunalités à travers
des nouveaux cantons à travers des
nouvelles régions
est-ce que avec naturellement les
impacts que ce sien naturellement sur le
l'équilibre financier des différentes
collectivités est-ce que la Commission
nationale d'évaluation le Conseil pardon
national d'évaluation des normes à
travailler sur sur
ce type de de discours est-ce que
les les
études d'impact échantillon
éventuellement été fait naturellement
dans le cadre de grands textes que vous
connaissez
on vous ont permis
ultérieurement d'évaluer s'il y a lieu
la qualité de ses études d'impact et de
façon globale est-ce que vous avez une
position de principe est-ce que le
Conseil national a une position de
principe sur cette volonté exacerbée des
gouvernements successifs je le répète
façon trans partisane de voir augmenter
la taille des différentes collectivités
alors on ne peut pas dire que le Conseil
est délibéré formellement sur la
question que vous posez mais je ne veux
surtout pas l'esquiver
personnellement j'ai le sentiment mais
qui est probablement mesurable c'est que
plus vous élargissez en taille
géographique en taille démographique une
collectivité plus vous éloignez le
pouvoir de là où il s'applique je suis
désolé de le présenter d'une manière
aussi synthétique et peut-être aussi
caricaturale mais je l'assume
comme la France est ainsi faite et qu'il
y a notamment des zones de faible
densité démographique le pouvoir va
vouloir organiser les relations entre
les différentes collectivités qui se
trouvent au sein du périmètre
comme si c'est collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas capables de
s'organiser entre elles
j'ai toujours pensé notamment à propos
de la loi d'autres que tous les articles
devraient être précédés à défaut de
convention contraire uneanime entre les
collectivités concernées de manière à ce
que le dispositif contraignant ne
s'applique que lorsque les collectivités
territoriales n'ont pas été capables de
s'entendre entre elles
mais en quoi peut-on affirmer que le
droit conçu à Paris sur la bonne
organisation entre collectivités
territoriales serait meilleur que le
droit voulu par les collectivités
elles-mêmes
ma collez vous je suis épris de liberté
je le suis pour les personnes physiques
je le suis pour les personnes publiques
que sont les collectivités territoriales
je pense que notre droit s'emporterait
mieux
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
chers collègues
question à moi j'avais une petite
question qui revient peut-être un peu
plus sur le rôle du CNN mais dans la loi
e3ds ou d'excédent travail de la
rapporteur Gatel et de Mathieu d'Arnaud
des dispositions qui obligent dorénavant
le gouvernement à motiver quand il vous
rendait un avis négatif et qu'il veut
déroger à la vie qui a été rendu je
voulais savoir ce que déjà vous avez une
évaluation et un peu de recul par
rapport à l'application et est-ce que
vous avez des exemples d'avis négatifs
qu'on crée rendu par le cnen
alors sur la motivation très franchement
on n'a pas vraiment progressé je trouve
que le Parlement a introduit ce
dispositif
utilement parce que au fond une
motivation c'est tout simplement un
dialogue le dial qui consiste à dire
nous pouvoir réglementaires nous ne
pensons pas pouvoir répondre à votre
souhait parce que tel ou tel ou tel
objectif serait contrarié si on faisait
droit à votre demande c'est un dialogue
on pourrait à la limite le comprendre
mais on ne vous répond pas sur ce sujet
on ne justifie pas une position
de pouvoir réglementaire qui est souvent
orienté par l'idée monsieur le sénateur
que vous évoquez tout à l'heure c'est
comme il faut que le texte convienne à
tout le monde quel que soit la taille
etc si un texte extrêmement rigide et
donc il n'y a pas de place finalement
pour la libre volonté des collectivités
concernées sur le deuxième point il me
semble que
très franchement
il n'y a il y a une précipitation dans
la rédaction des textes qui fait que
toute le dialogue
dialogue préalable qui pourrait être
extrêmement utile pour avoir le texte
qui connaîtrait l'application la plus
appropriée à chaque territoire quel que
soit la raison de la variété de notre
territoire national ce travail n'est pas
ce travail de dialogue n'est pas
respecté alors pas par mauvaise volonté
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a une course au
chiffre
un texte et supposé avoir besoin de
cases décrets d'application plus vite
ils vont être pris plus vite on aura
gagné la partie alors que c'est la
partie qui commence c'est pas la partie
qui est finie le décret d'application
c'est une partie qui commence
le gouvernement publie des
ratios de décret d'application
publiée dans un certain délai dans le
délai de six mois
je dois dire parce que j'aime la malice
que le Sénat publie chaque année un
rapport sur la publication des décrets
d'application qui est un rapport
purement quantitatif et pas du tout
qualitatif
moi je trouve que il y aurait une très
bonne occasion pour le Sénat de se
distinguer par rapport à l'Assemblée
nationale et d'avoir un rapport sur
l'application des lois qui soit rapport
de plus en plus qualitatif par rapport à
l'aspect qualitatif qui entre nous et
produit par le Secrétariat général du
gouvernement en permanence
d'autant nous on a parfois l'impression
que les décrets d'application sont
travaillés en temps masquées et sont
parfois anticipés dans leur rédaction
avant l'élaboration de la loi par par le
Sénat oui madame leur rapporteur
donc suite à la question de la
présidente pouvez-vous nous
pourriez-vous nous citer quelques
exemples de récent d'avis négatif du
cnen fondé sur une insuffisance une
insuffisance évaluation financière
préalable soit sur la création des
charges de charges supplémentaires pour
les sur la pardon
fondée sur une insuffisante évaluation
financière préalable soit sur la
création de charge supplémentaires pour
les collectivités territoriales si vous
avez quelques exemples vous avez un
projet d'arrêter qui est extrêmement
important qui est relatif à
l'instruction budgétaire comptable M57
je suis pas sûr que les conséquences
étaient anticipées
par les assemblées parlementaires ni
même par le ministère concerné j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt une
disposition qui est un peu passée en
force qui a suscité parce que le sujet
est technique qui n'a suscité
à ce stade aucune réaction mais il est
en train de se préparer des Colocs sur
le sujet qui vont faire apparaître à mon
avis les difficultés il y a un décret
qui porte sur les mesures relatives aux
dotations de l'État aux collectivité
territoriales et à la péréquation des
ressources fiscales là encore
concertation
quasiment
absente
les conséquences liées à la modification
de potentiel fiscal agrégé des ensembles
intercommunaux là encore vous n'avez pas
à la limite de d'options possibles vous
avez pas de
description des conséquences que nous
allons connaître donc s'agissant des
charges supplémentaires vous connaissez
le total que nous avons donné sur la
seule année 2002 2022 pardon sur 3
milliards 9 il y a 1,7 milliards de
robruth qui sont
exigés dans les années qui suivent donc
vous vous apercevez que il y a
absolument nécessité de
d'éviter ce genre de choses puisque vous
me demandez quels étaient d'autres
textes y aller les textes relatifs à la
température du système de chauffage et
de refroidissement des réseaux de
distribution de chaleur
et un milliard et demi résulte d'un
décret relatif au système d'automisation
d'automédisation pardonnez-moi et de
contrôle des bâtiments tertiaires
merci monsieur le Président et j'ai une
question supplémentaire de la part de
monsieur bachel qui m'ont tellement
absent donc il est en train de nous
regarder sur internet donc les essiennes
est-il compétent pour les projets de
normes qui régissent des compétences
optionnelles ou facultatives des
collectivités territoriales par exemple
dans le domaine de la petite enfance du
périscolaire
alors est-ce que le CNN est compétent
oui il est compétent pour toute mesure
qui a un impact financier pour les
collectivités territoriales
donc à notre président qui regarde qu'en
effet le compétences sur ce sujet
je rappelle que les assemblées
parlementaires peuvent
solliciter le CNN pour avoir un avis sur
tel ou tel point
je crois que le sénateur Richard a une
question
c'est
en fait j'ai encore deux questions
monsieur le Président
vous vous connaissez naturellement cette
je sais pas si une nouveauté mais cette
cette
façon de de préférer maintenant par
certains gouvernements que je ne citerai
pas préférer passer par des propositions
de loi que par des projets de loi en
d'autres termes
pour être tout à fait clair c'est un
projet de loi qui n'en est pas un
puisqu'il est porté par un parlementaire
c'est un projet de loi qui n'en n'est
pas un puisqu'il est porté par un
parlementaire mais on sait naturellement
d'où il vient donc c'est ce proposition
de loi le gros avantage naturellement de
se passer de l'étude d'impact
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
tendance à se développer ces dernières
années
certaines peuvent naturellement avoir
des impacts forts sur des collectivités
locales vous en doutez bien quel est
votre rôle à l'égard de telle
proposition de loi est-ce que
il y a pas d'étude d'impact au départ
vous vous
en êtes saisis vous n'en êtes pas saisi
mais quel est votre rôle deuxième petite
question très très incidente on voit
aussi fleurir dans un certain nombre de
textes de loi j'y pense parce qu'on est
en train de travailler notamment sur le
projet de loi immigration où on renvoie
à un décret
un texte réglementaire la fixation du
norme d'une norme
est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a pas lieu dans dans
tel
cas d'espèces
de demander qu'il y ait une étude
d'impact
et je sais pas comment la demander
puisqu'il s'agirait d'un texte
réglementaire n'est-il pas lieu dans la
loi alors peut-être je vais le dire
autrement de fixer de fixer la norme de
telle façon à ce qu'effectivement le
pouvoir réglementaire
comment dire soit lié par par la norme
qui est fixée dans la loi en d'autres
termes je
[Musique]
m'adresse à ceux qui sont membres de la
commission des lois mais notamment le
niveau de langage
de maîtrise du français que devra demain
posséder
une personne qui va demander une
intégralité un étranger qui va demander
une intégration en France
reste à l'heure actuelle du domaine dans
le projet de loi tel qu'il nous est
soumis de même réglementaire or on peut
peut-être se poser la question de savoir
si ceci est pas du domaine de la loi
alors est-ce qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
fixer des études d'impact plus souvent
avant de renvoyer cela un texte
réglementaire dans dans la loi monsieur
le président
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
cela
merci beaucoup alors sur la première
question je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment au départ de malice des
pouvoirs exécutifs simplement la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008
encore une fois a prévu une meilleure
répartition du pouvoir de proposition de
texte entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement et donc il a été ouvert un
nombre de séances déterminé par cette
loi organique qui relève du pouvoir
parlementaire sauf qu'on a un
parlementaire rationalisé depuis
tellement longtemps qu'il n'est pas
habitué à travailler en amont à la
préparation de proposition de loi et
donc on a constaté que plusieurs
gouvernements l'ont fait que ce sont les
gouvernements qui proposent à des
parlementaires des textes qui sont
présentés sous forme de proposition de
loi de proposition de loi alors que ce
sont quasiment des projets de loi alors
ceci ne font pas l'objet d'études
d'impact vous avez raison vous poser la
question nous ne les voyons pas c'est
d'ailleurs bien dommage mais c'est
difficile de faire autrement
sur votre deuxième question elle est
très importante
en effet l'article 34 et 37 de les
articles 34 et 37 de la Constitution
prévoit ce qui est du domaine de la loi
ce qui est du domaine du règlement donc
vous pouvez dans un certain nombre de
dispositions avoir une partie de ces
dispositions qui relève du domaine de la
loi et une autre partie qui relève du
pouvoir réglementaire c'est dans ce cas
là où pour ma part j'estime que les
amendements d'appel sont extrêmement
utiles parce qu'ils peuvent même s'ils
sont du domaine réglementaire permettre
d'interpeller le gouvernement pour voir
ce qu'il envisage comme norme
réglementaire à la suite de l'adoption
de la loi et je dois dire pour avoir été
membre du gouvernement que c'est pas
obligatoirement des questions agréables
ou
qu'on apprécie beaucoup parce que on est
sollicité en amont sur un travail que le
pouvoir réglementaire va souvent faire
après et donc je pense que c'est
extrêmement important pour le Parlement
d'attirer l'attention du gouvernement
sur la connaissance qu'il veut avoir des
mesures réglementaires qu'il entend
prendre à la suite de la disposition
législative
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente je suis le
président Lambert vous êtes un homme
connu je dirais même célèbre puisque
vous êtes un peu le père de la LOLF et
donc vous connaissez très bien la
mécanique budgétaire je vous ai entendu
avec quelqu'un satisfactions sur
comment dire on voudrait indépendance
l'indépendance de l'organe
quid véritablement de cette indépendance
lorsque vous êtes au sein de la
Direction générale des collectivités
territoriales si l'homme est
insoupçonnable sous son indépendance
d'esprit son expérience à ses
connaissances mais l'organe lui-même tel
qu'il est placé là où il est placé
est-ce que vous êtes véritablement
indépendant dans vos études dans les
moyens qui vous sont donnés dans les
ressources qui vous sont allouées pour
pouvoir donner des avis
libres
libres de toute influence et vous même
vous disiez dans une recommandation avec
votre homologue allemand qu'il faut
renforcer l'indépendance quand on dit
vous par cela avez-vous aujourd'hui les
moyens de votre liberté
merci beaucoup monsieur le sédatteur je
me souviens de vous quand vous étiez
député que j'étais au gouvernement et
nous avons d'ailleurs toujours eu en
sciences publiques des relations tout à
fait courtoises et agréable votre
question sur l'indépendance c'est une
question redoutable parce que autant
nous délibérons très librement et si
nous avons envie d'émettre à David
défavorable aucune influence ne nous
permettra ne permettra qu'on avait un
évéaborable cela étant la qualité de nos
travaux souffre d'un manque de moyens
pour pouvoir fonder nos avis sur des
travaux beaucoup plus approfondies donc
je crois que l'élargissement des moyens
est absolument indispensable pour pour
accroître encore la question de
l'indépendance vous avez raison de la
poser au regard de l'exemple allemand
qui me paraît aujourd'hui le plus abouti
dans des systèmes qui sont comparables
et l'exemple allemand est simple c'est
une autorité indépendante
je dois dire que ayant été sollicité par
le Sénat sur ce sujet j'avais émis la
vie que c'était pas obligatoirement
indispensable dans notre cas parce que
l'avantage que nous avons c'est que nous
avons un conseil composé de d'élus qui
sont majoritaires et demandent des
administrations et que nous avons sur
une table qui est comparable à celle-ci
autour de la table des hauts
fonctionnaires et des représentants des
collectivités territoriales et ce
dialogue entre eux est quand même
extrêmement précieux parce que vous avez
la question pratique qui est posée par
l'élu et parfois le haut fonctionnaire
est un peu surpris parce que il
n'imagine pas qu'on veut doivent
descendre dans le détail de la question
posée donc j'ai toujours pensé que ce
dialogue était fécond alors il faut
arriver à le concilier avec le souci
d'apprendre d'indépendance que vous
étiez tout à l'heure
donc la proposition que vous faites de
la fusion avec le SGG
vous auriez pu
pensez-vous de la création d'une
autorité administrative indépendante je
suis beaucoup n'aime pas ça dans sa
échappe à
au Parlement aux élus c'est des corps
intermédiaires on ne maîtrise pas bref
il y a un débat philosophique et de
sciences politiques dessus mais en étant
intégré au SGG S
c'est comment vous dire ça vous êtes
encore plus proche du pouvoir et
peut-être plus sous son influence est-ce
que cette fusion là vous paraît
efficace
alors vous avez raison de poser les
questions parce que dans mon esprit il
s'agit pas d'une fusion mais d'un
rattachement administratif
donc qui dératâchement administratifs
dit maintien des dépendances tout
simplement c'est un rapprochement on va
dire géographique des bureaux qui permet
la l'échange d'information dans des
délais très courts mais vous avez raison
de souligner qui ne faudrait pas que ça
soit une fusion puisque alors là
naturellement ça serait le rattachement
total et la dépendance totale au pouvoir
exécutif
sur sur les autorités administratives
indépendantes
vous savez il y a 50% de ceux qui
siègent au CNN qui pensent comme vous
qui pensent que l'autorité
administrative indépendante serait sans
doute préférable bon encore une fois
j'ai souscrivais
éventuellement si nous pouvions ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans les autorités
indépendantes
introduire quand même un collège mixte
entre les élus les administrations parce
que je constate quand même que ce
dialogue est très utile
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
chers collègues
merci président merci monsieur le
Président pour votre prestation
j'avoue que je ne connais pas votre
votre structure n'avez-vous pas peur que
en sollicitant de notre part davantage
de saisine de votre part n'avez-vous pas
peur que nous ayons un alourdissement
des délais par rapport à la fois la
parution des décrets d'applications à la
parution de la loi etc merci
donc je vais rester dans ce registre
j'ai pas le sentiment que les Français
attendent des lois tout en permanence à
toute berzingue si vous permettez
l'expression et des règlements
supplémentaires je crois qu'ils en ont
une certaine dose et ils en attendent
pas davantage donc c'est le processus un
peu plus long
pour qu'il soit de meilleure qualité ce
serait plutôt un progrès je n'ai aucun
doute là-dessus
mon avis la précipitation est une des
causes de la mauvaise qualité du droit
actuellement
vous savez le droit
c'est un corps de règles qui nécessite
de prendre en compte un certain nombre
de données qui ne sont pas du tout
compatibles avec l'improvisation ou la
spontanéité voilà pourquoi je pense
franchement que
avoir un petit peu plus de délai pour
réfléchir aux conséquences du droit
qu'on élabore serait plutôt un progrès
comme nous sommes à la fin de cette
audition d'avoir ce que j'ai compris
madame la Présidente je voulais vous
dire que c'est son probablement la
dernière fois que j'ai la chance d'être
accueilli par votre mission puisque mes
fonctions vont cesser puisque je
n'exerce plus de mental
probablement à compter de l'automne
prochain et je voudrais vraiment émettre
ici devant vous le vœu que le Sénat
dans la fidélité à la volonté qu'il a eu
en 2012 et 2013 de créer le C2N reste
vigilant pour le protéger pour le
soutenir pour enrichir ces missions et
pour enrichir ses moyens la voie des
collectivités territoriales pour
l'améliorer l'amélioration du droit de
la mise en oeuvre des politiques
publiques est absolument indispensable
et c'est probablement Sénat plus encore
qu'une autre assemblée de veiller à ce
que il y est une instance qui le
renseigne en permanence sur les
difficultés qu'il rencontre dans le dial
ogue entre l'État prescripteur et les
collectivités territoriales
exécutérisent voilà le message que je
voulais adresser sans aucune nostalgie
et bien un moment il faut savoir
s'arrêter mais le je crois vraiment que
l'oeuvre du Sénat créant le CNN doit
être maintenu et surveillé
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci évidemment pour votre engagement
et je pense que votre message est
entendu ici au sein de la Chambre des
territoires nous sommes évidemment
toujours très attentifs à la place et à
l'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales et
sachez que nous veillerons évidemment à
ce que le cnen continue à exercer ses
missions qui sont évidemment au service
de la même cause que celle que nous
portons ici
alors je crois que Antoine Fèvre avait
une petite question je voulais pas
intervenir pour pas te prolonger les bas
mais à la suite de ce que vient de dire
à Lambert ça me permet de de
m'interroger et de l'interroger sur la
nécessité peut-être pour pour le
successeur
d'entrevoir un système de de contrôle de
désignation comme on le fait pour un
certain nombre d'autres autorités quel
est son avis sur le sujet
à Lambert avait une toute légitimité
pour assumer avec brio cette fonction
quel est le son avis sur sur cette
nécessaire je pense que
les associations nationales d'élus qui
sont celles qui présentent les candidats
au cnen doivent être naturellement
consultés c'est elle qui instruisent le
cnen d'un certain nombre de données au
quotidien et leur vie me paraît
essentiel je crois que les organes de
relation habituelle avec le CN au sein
du Parlement seront probablement
solliciter pour avoir également leur
avis si je peux dessiner non pas un
portrait
que je ne parce que j'ai pas du tout
réfléchi à la succession mais je crois
que une personne qui est l'expérience du
Parlement me paraît indispensable
une expérience passée éventuellement ne
pose aucun problème une expérience de
l'exécutif est aussi utile parce qu'on
est en relation permanente avec les
éducatifs et naturellement un lien très
très étroit avec les collectivités
territoriales
oui
vous êtes le père de l'un des pères de
la Golf et il y a une révision récemment
et il n'est pas nécessaire pour le
gouvernement de produire des études
d'impact pour une loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale
pour une loi de finance
et on a à peu près le même problème pour
les avis du Conseil d'État pour la
transparence quel est votre avis
aujourd'hui faudrait-il introduire
nécessairement ou sur certains aspects
j'imagine une loi de finance et un peu
compliqué d'avoir des études d'impact
sur tous les trucs mais quand même
est-ce que pour la transparence même si
je peux comprendre que le gouvernement
veut préserver ses conseils puisque
l'espèce le Conseil d'État est le
conseil de l'État mais est-ce que pour
la transparence et nous mettre au même
niveau d'information est-ce que la LOLF
pourrait à votre avis évoluer davantage
imposer plus de
participation de collaboration entre le
Parlement et le gouvernement ou l'os
empêcher l'état d'agir comme une comme
il le veut dans les délais qu'il a
décidé non non je comprends bien votre
question et je pense d'ailleurs que ce
dialogue entre le Parlement et le
pouvoir exécutif existe
assez souvent avec les commissions de
finances
mais cela étant et ça c'est un ancien
ministre du Budget qui vous le dit
la neualité budgétaire est une nécessité
mais les trajectoires de finances
publiques ne sont plus annuels c'est du
reste pour ça que j'ai beaucoup insisté
tout à l'heure sur la loi de
programmation de finance publique et sur
le programme de stabilité parce que une
stratégie budgétaire aujourd'hui même
dans les collectivités territoriales
vous savez qu'il y a un débat
d'orientation budgétaire qui n'est pas
cannelle il est aussi parfois
trillionale donc on voit bien monsieur
le sénateur que
la conception ou la gestion des des
finances publiques se fait sur plusieurs
années donc c'est au moment de la loi de
programmation et du
encore une fois pour avoir été budget
vous savez
la loi de finance annuelle elle est
très très contrainte et donc on pourrait
imaginer qu'il y ait en amont beaucoup
de concertation cela étant elle est
tellement contrainte que je ne suis pas
sûr que il y ait beaucoup d'efficacité
merci beaucoup encore de nouveaux
monsieur le Président chaleureusement
pour ces échanges qui je pense
nourriront très largement les travaux de
la mission elle en a quelques annonces
paroissiales à vous faire avant de se
quitter toi pour la mission et moi pour
la délégation alors je te laisse très
bien je voudrais un bon à mon tour vous
remercier monsieur le Président de
d'avoir accepté de venir et d'être notre
première personnalité auditionnée au
sein de cette mission donc merci
vraiment vos propos ouvriers nous ont
éclairés sur le travail du CNN dans
votre mission qui je dois l'avouer aussi
je ne connaissais pas très très bien et
donc vraiment c'est vraiment un plus
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
donc je voudrais seulement vous dire
pour conclure que nous débuterons à
partir du 15 mars un cycle d'audition
des associations d'élus locaux elle nous
permettront de prolonger ses échanges et
d'évoquer notamment le manque de
concertation des élus locaux de la
préparation des normes je crois que ça a
été ça a été dit et je signale un
particulier que nous entendrons le 21
mars André Laignel a sa double qualité
de premier vice-président de l'AMF et de
président du Comité des finances locales
merci
vous recevrez voilà les invitations et
dernière annonce paroissiale cette
fois-ci pour la délégation collectivité
territoriale c'est la demande de la
présidente pour appeler qu'il y a les
états généraux de la simplification des
normes le 16 mars qui sera le moment
d'avoir le retour sur la consultation
des élus sur cette question de
simplification et ça sera aussi
l'occasion de signer une convention avec
le cneen et donc on aura l'occasion de
se revoir à cette occasion voilà en tout
cas merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à tous les membres du cnen merci
chers collègues à très vite